[Musique]
Simon Lebrun et Pascal Desrochers
contemple le fleuve Saint-Laurent ils
attendent le MSC donata importe
conteneur de la compagnie maritime MSC
qu'ils vont piloter jusqu'au port de
Montréal il est 8h30 du matin le navire
passe sous le pont de Trois-Rivières
c'est le moment d'embarquer sur le
porte-container qui poursuit sa route au
milieu du fleuve
et de grimper jusqu'à la passerelle
la salle de commande du bateau pour les
deux pilotes c'est leur bureau le pilote
maritime est un expert ou une experte
locale qui se joint à l'équipe de
passerelle dont fait partie le capitaine
afin de les aider amener le navire à bon
port il ne réside pas à boire il ne fait
pas partie de l'équipage permanent
chaque bateau commercial qui navigue sur
le fleuve Saint-Laurent entre Les
Escoumins et les Grands Lacs et manœuvré
par des pilotes ils sont 230 à assurer
les différents tronçons qui sectionnent
le fleuve
la corporation des pilotes du
Saint-Laurent central fondé en 1873
rassemble les 126 pilotes qui navigue
entre Québec et Montréal
Simon et Pascal font les allers-retours
Trois-Rivières Montréal
quelques 120 km et une soixantaine de
courbes à faire prendre à ses
mastodontes de la mer
le MSC donata mesure 255 mètres de long
par 32 dollars il pèse 68000 tonnes
c'est parmi les plus gros navires que
l'on peut croiser sur le fleuve
c'est 245 mètres il y a certains
endroits où on a un cheval naturel qui
va s'élargir devenir pilote sur le
fleuve est un long processus quatre ans
d'études un institut maritime du Québec
à Rimouski puis au moins 5 ans de
navigation partout dans le monde pour
devenir capitaine et deux autres années
de formation pour devenir pilote et
gravir les échelons par la suite on dit
que pour former un pilote qui pourra
piloter tous les navires sur le fleuve
Saint-Laurent ça prend presque 10 ans à
partir du moment on devient apprenti
pilote jusqu'à temps où on a la
formation nécessaire pour piloter un
navire comme celui sur lequel on est
aujourd'hui donc on est rendu 17 à 20
années
au total pour prendre quelqu'un qui
déciderait d'aller faire carrière dans
ce domaine-là la corporation doit
d'ailleurs gérer l'enjeu de la relève
car beaucoup de pilotes ont pris ou vont
prochainement prendre leur retraite un
métier très bien payé en moyenne 300000
dollars par an mais très stressant et
exigeant les pilotes travaillent de jour
comme de nuit 24 heures sur 24 365 jours
par an et ont quatre heures d'avis avant
de connaître leur affectation donc la
gestion de notre sommeil de notre repos
sur une
est un défi personnel qu'il faut bien
gérer tous les ans 6000 navires sur le
fleuve Saint-Laurent et les pilotes de
la corporation des pilotes du
Saint-Laurent central font 14 000
affectations annuellement autrement dit
toutes les 40 minutes jour et nuit un
pilote embarque sur un navire entre
Québec et Montréal
et si pilotes sont un maillon central
dans la chaîne de l'économie canadienne
c'est l'aorte économique du Québec et
d'une grande partie du Canada c'est le
fleuve Saint-Laurent 80% de ce qui sera
mal sur les tablettes des commerces au
transit par le fleuve
c'est des milliards dans l'économie
canadienne qui transitent sur le fleuve
alors c'est une artère économique de
première importance ne te principale
outil pour naviguer dans ce secteur sont
les radars côté sécurité rien n'est
laissé au hasard en plus des instruments
de navigation qui sont sur les navires
les pilotes apportent leur GPS et cartes
électroniques afin de coupler les
données et vérifier qu'il n'y a pas
d'erreur une démarche indispensable
quand il n'y a pas de visibilité notre
bilan de sécurité c'est
99.95% des transits se font sans aucun
incident c'est un peu ça qui nous
entende guillemets c'est qu'on est un
prix mécanique dans des endroits plus
délicats ou lorsqu'on rencontre un autre
navire si on avait une machine si les
instruments de navigation sont
indispensables au pilotage ainsi que les
bouées et les repères alignés tout le
long du chenal l'outil le plus précieux
du pilote ce sont ses yeux d'église en
ligne avec le coin d'une maison ça me
donne une ligne de positionner il peut
pas y avoir d'erreur c'est une ligne qui
est parfaite la navigation hivernale est
un défi supplémentaire pour les pilotes
avec la brume les tempêtes de neige les
glaces sur le fleuve
d'où l'importance d'avoir ses experts à
la barre sur ce fleuve réputé capricieux
ils sont d'ailleurs assignés à un seul
tronçon durant toute leur carrière c'est
la nature même du travail du pilote
c'est de connaître par coeur un tronçon
particulier on est vraiment un expert de
la navigation locale
[Musique]
il est près de 18h quand le MSC donata
accoste enfin au quai du Port de
Montréal
ses missions accomplies pour Simon et
Pascal jusqu'au prochain avis